something that may be causing another
issue with all of this the office has
been flooded with robo calls dieter
director Heather corporate held a
virtual news conference this morning she
says they are working to fix that issue
she also said despite pending claims
being down thousands are still looking
for answers about why they haven't
gotten their money yet the bulk of those
individual claims have separation issues
so for the whatever reason they
separated from their employment either
their employer is disputing the
separation and disputing unemployment
benefits or there is some other
complicated requirement for us she says
they are still hiring additional staff
members and are working to improve the
call system we're also getting
complaints into our newsroom from gig
workers who applied for PA and are also
waiting to get their money there is a
protest set to take place today I'm
outside the grants lawyer building it's
from 1 to 5 o'clock this afternoon
love a lot more on that coming up in our
evening newscasts